for some that don't know your background
if you don't mind taking a moment and
sharing your background that'd be great
how long do you have yeah we got two
hours
I could start from the beginning but um
I'll give you the shortened version and
you can unpick it as you like that
absolutely so I joined hezbo Tahir at
the age of 16 after facing uh some very
severe violent uh racist attacks where I
grew up in Essex in the UK being
um the number of people that look like
me you could count on perhaps one hand
uh and it was a very different time we
were the first generation
um born and raised in the UK to Muslim
parents and so it was it was a an
interesting experiment because we are
the four I'm 45 years old now so we were
the first generation to have this um
these questions around identity in the
west being Muslim uh our parents as
migrants never really had to face those
questions because they were always the
migrants who came so they were still
always in my case my parents came from
Pakistan they were Pakistani migrants in
Britain but we being born and raised
there had to kind of grapple with these
questions of what it meant to be a
Muslim born in the west so when we were
facing a lot of that violent racism
and I'm talking machete attacks Hammer
attacks when I say violent it was brutal
um I witnessed my first murder at 17 uh
stabbing to death who was doing the
attacking these were born British so
this was a group of uh neo-nazis uh they
affiliated with combat 18 uh which is a
um if it was formed
um as a paramilitary organization in
Northern Ireland by um serving soldiers
who were fighting uh the Irish
republicanism there and they became Uber
nationalist in that sense and uh 18
stands for the uh order of the letters
in the alphabet of Adolf Hitler's
initials so a being one and H being
eight these were guys they weren't
messing around uh multiple friends of
ours had either had hammers put to their
heads and
stabbed all over their bodies and we
I've been as I say but before that
murder at 17 but most of my uh I
witnessed more knife fights in my
teenage years than most people uh and
participated in that most people will
have in their entire lives um that has a
brutalizing effect on the psychology of
a young boy
so at 16
um with the Bosnia genocide unfolding in
Europe against again it's reminisce in
particular against Muslims I became very
very uh disassociated from society uh
became very uh Angry with the world and
at 16 as I say joined hezbollahir uh
that took me on another sort of chapter
it was a long journey I ended up on
their leadership I ended up exporting
the group from Britain to Denmark to
Pakistan where I was the one of the
first British Pakistani members to
co-found the organization in Pakistan uh
we uh our aim was to create a global
um theocracy in the name of my faith
tradition which I still uh adhere to and
do not reject whatsoever just to make
that clear to everybody what I critiqued
was the politicization of that Faith
tradition but the aim at the time we
wanted to create a global theocracy that
would impose one reading of that Faith
tradition over Society
um by law ironically a very European
westphalian concept which was
owed more to
um
colonialism and the interwar uh fascism
period than it did to the tradition to
the pluralistic tradition of Islam but
that's what we discuss in that book you
mentioned with Sam Harris but um I ended
up as I say exporting this revolution to
various countries ended up in Egypt I
landed one day before the 9 11 attacks
and the security climate around the
world completely changed and we though
we were non-violent we were if you like
um we were the trotskies to the
starlings of that kind of world so we
were more on the intellectual
revolutionary side as opposed to
violence 911 changed the calculation for
everybody and in Egypt they had a
security round up after 9 11 and we were
rounded up with hundreds of Egyptians
um uh we were then blindfolded
um we had our hands tied behind our
backs it with Rags they'd run out of
handcuffs they'd handcuffs they ran it
up so many people uh we were then taken
into their dungeons where they began
torturing everybody with uh
electrocution eventually uh we were
after a period of solitary confinement I
think about three and a half months
eventually we were put on trial and I
was sentenced to five years as a
political prisoner Tried by an emergency
court in Egypt not under the
Constitutional setup but tried in the
State of Emergency the Hosny Mubarak had
kept in that country since the
assassination of Anwar Sadat in 1981. uh
the country never left the state of
emergency so they were able to
arbitrarily detain people they had
forget Guantanamo Bay to be honest it
was a picnic compared to what we saw
they had people in in prisons without
charge and without trial for over 20
years but in addition to the torture
which wasn't just stress positions as it
is and I say just obviously every form
of torture is um is abhorrent but what
we see in in the Press about
um uh Guantanamo Bay and even abor was
nothing compared to what was going on
inside these prisons uh all uh mind you
while Tony Blair was taking free
holidays um being hosted by Jose Mubarak
while we were in those prisons as the
letters have recently been leaked where
Sherry Blair his wife has been
discussing those free holidays uh I
don't forget things like that but either
way
um we were sentenced to five years at
which point we were adopted by Amnesty
International as prisoners of conscience
because as I say there was no suggestion
even in the trial of any violence and I
spent the next five years in uh four and
a bit to be precise in maseratoto prison
with the surviving assassins of the
former president Anwar Sadat with the
leaders and founders of all of the
Jihadi as well as islamist groups in
Egypt at the time uh the leaders and
founders of Gamal islamia you're all in
there together in there together as I
say the Assassins were there those who
weren't executed in the case they all
became friends of mine the leader of the
Muslim Brotherhood
um uh Dr mohammedia Who Wasn't the
leader at the time he is now Muhammad
Morsi who since died he became the
leader after Mubarak was overthrown uh
amen Nord was a liberal prisoner from
Hezbollah Hezbollah
uh so we had uh pretty much it was a
political University how long were you
guys all together
um for the entire time in that prison so
I was there for just over four years
yeah so is this if if I'm painting a
picture of my mind was this daily
conversations debates you know going
through history you know ideas being
talked about is that kind of how it was
absolutely I I was a student at the time
I was studying Arabic I'm a graduate um
in Arabic in the Arabic language from
soas part of the University of London
and that's ostensibly why I went to
Egypt so I continued with my studies I
spent that time in uh prison studying uh
all all aspects of Islamic theology
um Islamic exegesis
Quran recitation and memorization Arabic
language the fuss had the classical
Arabic language
which is the jurisprudence the uh
science of Hadith interpretation uh it
because we had uh people in there that
there was no Rhyme or Reason as to who
was thrown in there other than suspicion
of a you know by a dictator so you had
genuine in scholars in there as well and
we I spent most of my time studying and
debating who was who was most uh
convincing
and simply because they were good at
debating again who was who was most
convicted in their beliefs
I have very little difficulty
differentiating between polemicists and
uh substance because I spent most of my
life training other people in how to
argue and and convince people so for me
it wasn't about poemics and um you spend
most of the real life teaching people
how to argue and debate yep because
hezbollah's methodology was ideological
propaganda
um we we trained people in uh in idle in
some of the tactics you saw uh During
the covid period which we can come to uh
weren't new to me at all we would train
people in in in the methods of
dissemination of ideas for the purposes
of ideological Warfare
um and that's why we were put in jail
because that was deemed very dangerous
um our purpose was to recruit army
officers uh and to eventually convince
them to instigate military coups did you
succeed I've recruited a few army
officers yeah yeah in Pakistan and uh
and um mainly in Pakistan actually the
the people I spoke to at the time so if
you can if you can go back and and the
again for you to be in there it's kind
of like a story of somebody saying yeah
you know I was in Rucker you know a park
and I was there and for about two years
it was me Michael you know such and such
and Joe Kobe and all these I mean
obviously these guys come from different
areas but if you put all of them at the
same time and they're all think tank for
two years what are those games like so
what are the conversations like so for
me what I'm asking you is who was most
convincing where you sat there and you
said that's a very good point they're
making for doing this for example if we
make an argument of U.S is the biggest
enemy and here's what they're doing and
you're like okay that's a very good
argument I've never heard before versus
who was a hundred percent convicted that
you couldn't sway them at all based on
your memories so the by the time we got
in there was a movement afoot in Egypt
and across the Islamic world of what was
called The Mirage at which is the
revisions of jihadist ideology and uh
there were books written uh by some of
the leaders of these Jihadi groups uh by
the leaders of Gamal islamia for example
I still have those books at home in
Arabic with my hand written annotations
on the sidelines of those books and the
these were revisions of jihadist thought
that were uh that I think were
profoundly impactful and they were
genuine and uh really influential in
convincing a lot of these uh more
hardcore militant ideologues that
violence isn't the way to bring about
change isn't yeah terroristic violence
is not the way to bring about political
change so they they were um they were
conversations we were having as I say
with uh former members Founders and
leaders of Gamal islamia
the Assassins of Sadat had also come to
those conclusions and had abandoned
their former jihadist ideology if
islamism is the desire to impose one
version of Islam over Society jihadism
is the use of force to bring about
islamism just to be clear and when I use
those term those terms that's what I
mean that's very distinct from Islam and
Jihad Islam is a faith tradition that is
known it's one of the abrahamic faiths
and Allah in Aramaic means God Jesus
when he spoke Aramaic would say Allah or
Elohim
went to Syrian Aramaic we say absolutely
so it just means the same word it's the
same Source uh God I don't use there's a
word because I think it's loaded in the
English language so even in English when
I'm speaking I prefer to say Allah just
so people understand that um ultimately
we're speaking of the same subject
matter here and and Islam in that sense
is is distinct from islamism the desire
to impose Islam over Society Jihad
coming back to those terms again means
struggle
so in the verb you can say it just means
I struggle and then of course there are
many various manifest manifestations of
struggle primarily we are our enemies is
within us and our solution often and
always actually is within us as well so
struggle uh should be seen in that
context of the struggle struggle to
overcome ourselves
it can be a struggle against the other
in many instances such as occupation I'm
the pacifist if somebody invades Britain
I will fight
and so I think that um jihadism though
is that is is the is the use of force to
impose islamism so that's why I Define
these terms so we're not talking of
Islam and Jihad back to your question I
haven't forgotten
um in in the prisons there were people
that were still subscribing to the
islamist and jihadist ideologies and
wanted to either use Force to impose
that on others or take over a system and
do so
but most of the
the leaders and founders of those
organizations by then had come around to
this idea uh that violence wasn't the
way so ironically we were the ideologues
when we were when we entered that jail
now ordinarily when you go through
torture uh it makes you even more Angry
even more
entrenched in your view and even less
willing to compromise because of the
anger and because of the inability to
separate the pain and the anguish and
the trauma from what you experienced
from being able to think clearly I don't
know for whatever reason in my case I
spent those five years debating And
discussing by the end of it I could I
and I read all those books I mentioned
the Mirage at all the revisions of the
in The jihadist Thinking by the end of
it even though I didn't leave the group
until a year after my departure from
maserat or a prison I could no longer
sustain my own conviction uh that what I
had thought was Islam the faith and
therefore needed to be proselytized uh
was what I had come to believe I could
no longer sustain that conviction and so
I had to uh leave so I'd say I became
influenced by these people that you were
asking of those that in their older
years had matured took one any one above
the other no no it was no collected yeah
it was a collective group of um and it
was so diverse and different I mean I
mentioned Eamonn North from Hezbollah he
was a liberal political prisoner we had
um uh we had uh Saturday Ibrahim was
quite a well-known Egyptian sociologist
who was jailed for questioning mubarak's
attempt uh to to give power to his son
afterwards Jamal Mubarak um and yet we
had Communists in there obviously the
majority were as a messenger Hadith but
just to give you an idea there were
there were people that are converted to
Christianity that were thrown in jail
for being apostates from Islam to
Christianity and there were there were
people that converted to Islam that were
thrown in jail and we had a running joke
at the time in prison that in under
Hosni mubarak's Egypt if you change your
mind from anything to anything it
doesn't matter which way you go thinking
is what what would get you put into
prison so imagine the diversity of
thought it was really for me that was my
real University so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]